hey 42 here I think it was the
philosopher Bubba from Forrest Gump who
said shrimp is the fruit of the sea
to which you may reply no it's not
shrimp are crustaceans which is true of
course but for argument's sake let me
just ask you what even is a fruit
you've heard that little factoid that a
tomato is actually a fruit no doubt the
most popular fruit in the world it turns
out the other Contender for Top Banana
is well the banana but even bananas
can't be framed as fruit not really
distantly related to Ginger the banana
tree is actually a herb and the stem is
made of Pulp not wood the banana itself
is a berry just like avocados cucumbers
and watermelons but unlike raspberries
mulberries hunt strawberries which are
not berries at all
neither are blackberries those are
things people used to write emails on in
the 90s
to further blur these linguistic lines
botanists call things like strawberries
false fruit or pseudocarps even though
they don't look anything like carp some
shrimp however do look like bananas just
ask the banana prawn so it seems Bubba
may have been onto something when he
celebrated shrimp's fruitiness or
perhaps he just polished off a bag of
those strangely addictive shrimp and
banana sweets which for the first time
in my life are now starting to make
sense
anyway it's time to bring this quirky
comparison to an end after all bananas
and shrimp belong to totally different
kingdoms of the natural world
bananas have been selectively bred by
humans for more than seven thousand
years those little black spots of the
remnants of seeds that were originally
much bigger and made them virtually
inedible
and today in Uganda we're even
genetically engineering a new super
banana packed with extra vitamin A and
iron
shrimp on the other hand that's the last
time we talk about bananas in this video
promise followed a darwinian process
known as divergent evolution
when populations of the same species are
separated usually geographically each
group develops distinct attributes to
adapt to the challenges unique to their
environment
Millennia later those Divergent
populations lose the ability to breed
and eventually something called
speciation occurs which is where new and
distinct species are born and hence we
arrive at the hero of today's video the
pistol shrimp
the word shrimp is sometimes used as an
insult but despite their diminutive
stature pound for pound or actually gram
for gram some Divergent species of
shrimp have evolved some of the
deadliest attacks in the natural world
take the mantis shrimp which holds the
Guinness World Record for the strongest
self-powered strike of any animal
although like fruit that pretends to be
carp this is not a shrimp at all but a
stumped a pot on the other claw the
pistol shrimp is the real deal you may
not have heard of it but you may have
heard it
only you probably didn't realize what it
was if you've ever been scuba diving or
snorkeling near a coral reef you'll
likely have heard the snapping or
popping noises emanating through the
water like you've just submerged your
head in a bowl of rice krispies
but that wasn't puffed rice you
perceived it was the popping of the
pistol shrimp such has been their
evolutionary Excellence that hundreds of
types of pistol shrimp exist in the
world's oceans and though they're
generally found in warmer Waters there
are also cold and fresh water varieties
they're pretty adaptable and habitats
include oyster reefs seagrass Flats
sponges and the Sandy ocean floor where
they build Burrows
sometimes called snapping shrimp they
grow to between three and five
centimeters and weigh about 25 grams
looking at this small Speck of sea life
you wouldn't think it poses much of a
threat to anything
but hold on a minute crop into that claw
and you'll notice something obscure
that's one hell of a chunky claw half
the length of its body in fact
the thing is it isn't really a claw at
all it's a goddamn revolver
functioning in a similar way to a
trigger and Hammer mechanism on a gun
one side of the claw ratchets open 90
degrees just like cutting a handgun then
with his weapon primed the shrimp holds
his shot with his prey in mind then bang
the claw snaps shut so quickly it's
almost imperceptible even on the
slickest slo-mo cameras but this
precisely primed pistol just fired a
projectile of pure water that petrified
its prey
we think of the ocean as peaceful
perhaps the only noise being the lapping
of the waves but the sea is a symphony
of snapping sounds thanks largely to the
pistol shrimp a single snap can be as
loud as 218 decibels by comparison
traffic is about 70 decibels a sonic
boom from an aircraft is 120 and
gunshots reach just 140. actually the
pistol shrimped water dwelling neighbor
the sperm whale is one of the few
animals that's louder than it making
noises exceeding 240 decibels however
considering sperm whales can weigh up to
80 tons and are roughly 3.5 million
times the size of the pistol shrimp I
think we all know who's the real ocean
goats hint it's not the Giant floating
sperm monster
sometimes huge colonies of pistol shrimp
can be found living in sponges the
almighty din emitted by this crustacean
crowd is so loud it can Cloud underwater
Communications
during the second world war it was
discovered that the racket of a shrimp
Colony could conceal submarines from
sonar detection I'm sure it was by no
coincidence it was around this time that
research into the pistol shrimp really
began in Earnest for a long time
scientists believed it was simply the
contact of the claws as they come
together that created the noise just
like when humans clap turns out their
logic was fishy four there was much more
going on inside that claw biologists
studying snapping shrimps discovered a
novel joint previously unknown to
science
it's a type of slip joint where the only
thing keeping the claw cocked open is a
small Ridge or fulcrum
until a point when the force is so
overwhelming that the fulcrum is
overcome and so the claw snapshot
the slip joint achieves this snapping
action far faster than any other
configuration of claw so how exactly
does this supreme snapping generate a
bullet made of water
well the moving part of the claw has a
rounded piece at its base that acts as a
plunger
this plunger perfectly slots into a
socket on the thick side of the claw if
you've ever made coffee with a French
press or used a bicycle pump you'll know
that plenty of pressure can build up
behind a plunger in the case of the
pistol shrimp it's water not air that's
trapped inside the socket and squeezed
out with significant Force
all this water needs to go somewhere and
there's a little Groove which directs a
jet of water forwards as it escapes from
the claw
and this is no ordinary water gun though
the claw closes at such high speeds that
it creates something called cavitation
Bubbles and cavitation Bubbles means
trouble in fluid dynamics Bernoulli's
principle states that when a liquid
travels at high speed it simultaneously
experiences a drop in pressure as a
result small air bubbles in the liquid
expand but when the liquid slows down
again the pressure suddenly increases
and the bubbles implode this causes a
shock wave along with a snap
captains must be cautious of cavitation
because it can damage a ship's
propellers and when some fish like tuna
move too quickly through the water they
create cavitation bubbles behind them
that can damage their own tails in fact
tuna are frequently found with tail
lesions created by these deadly bubbles
but in the case of the pistol shrimp the
cavitation bubble is used to stun or
kill its prey this bubble bullet travels
at 97 kilometers per hour as well as a
deafening crack it causes a brief
increase in temperature
heating the surrounding water to
4700 degrees Celsius which isn't far off
the surface of the Sun at 5500 C the
sound of the collapsing bubble also
produces a flash of Light which is
something known as sonoluminescence
The Flash is so brief that it's
imperceptible to the human eye
although this Tiny Terror possesses
Titanic power it uses it mostly to
defend its territory lying in weight
inside a burrow until its prey passes
close enough to unleash bubbly death
although the pistol stream has been
known to use its claw for communication
too one particular species the Randall's
pistol shrimp forms a symbiotic
relationship with the Gobi fish they
will live in the same burrow together
and the pistol shrimp acts as the
Homemaker digging and maintaining the
tunnels even closing off the entrance at
night when it's bedtime
meanwhile the Gobi protects the shrimp
when the two head topside
the shrimp has poor eyesight and so the
Gobi acts as the lookout one of the
shrimp's antenna will rest on the gobi's
tail fin and if the Gobi flicks its fin
the shrimp instantly feels it and
Retreats to the safety of the borough
Beyond its massive size and ability to
generate freakish underwater Fireball
explosions there's something else
amazing about this colossal claw
it can be regrown
sure there are other animals in nature
that are able to regenerate lost body
parts like geckos who lose their tails
but the snapping shrimp is perhaps the
most spectacular
departed from its super claw the
remaining smaller claw starts to grow
which soon becomes the new snapping claw
meanwhile The Stomp of the old snapping
claw begins to grow into a new claw too
to replace the normal Nipper so
basically the claws end up swapping
sides along with all of the necessary
rewiring that is needed to regulate the
sensory input and motor control
in the world we live in today language
is not often used sparingly people use
words like incredible which is supposed
to mean something that's impossible to
believe to describe something like a
potato salad advertisers use phrases
like small But Mighty to describe a
concentrated dishwashing liquid
but I think we can all agree that in the
case of the pistol shrimp such
superlatives are especially deserved
because the pistol shrimp truly is a
stunning fruit
thanks for watching